let's join now the retired General Sir
Richard Baron's former commander of the
UK's Joint Forces command
um how seriously should this be taken
then you obviously heard from our
security and defense editor there
yes and I absolutely agree with with
Deborah Haynes that
um right now is the time for um cool
heads and uh and the facts and the and
the facts will be established probably
in daylight when the the parts or
whatever caused this explosion such as
bits of a missile will be located and
they're relatively easy to identify and
the radar tracks through the sky at the
time the explosion uh could also be in
investigated because the stakes are
really high that that if and it would be
extraordinary Russia had decided to fire
a missile into NATO territory and we
should recognize that it's probably
unlikely Russia would choose to Target a
random grain silo in a village with a
population of just 400 to start a war
with with NATO but if Russia has decided
to do that then you know then this world
this world of ours is taking a turn that
no one could possibly have imagined even
even a month ago far more likely is an
explanation that the a missile has gone
Rogue in others it's malfunctioned or
it's been deflected and ended up in
Poland with tragic consequences so
um exactly as your correspondences
describe you need to know what happened
what the intent was behind it and then
people should take a view on it and and
I think a sort of International Junior
School football match whirring up the
rhetic around this right now is is
deeply unhelpful
yes and I guess there are actually Four
possible explanations if indeed this was
related to the Ukraine war one of you
said it was deliberate but unlikely
another is a missile overshoot or gone
wrong the other is that air defense
systems had been deployed and this was a
Remnant part of a missile or indeed part
of the Interceptor itself we know that
Ukraine received nasams from America
they've got their own s-300s Ukraine's
existing Soviet era air defense systems
so there are a number of explanations
um for this so what does happen now and
how closely will NATO allies consult do
you think
um because this process of verifying
what happened is already underway as far
as we understand it so all eyes will now
be on the site of the explosion and
people uh experts in the technology will
be looking for missile debris another
debris to identify what it was that has
that has killed these two people's poor
souls this evening and and then when
they've identified what it was they can
then start start to investigate how it
got there and maybe what the motive was
behind it and really only when that is
clearer and clear in my view should the
North Atlantic Council and NATO members
uh take a definitive position on this
because to do so beforehand would it
would it would imply they were prepared
to decide on something really
significant in the absence of actually
uh knowing the facts and and the other
point about this evening is there's a
this huge attention on this uh explosion
in Poland for very very good reasons but
the fact is during the course of today
Russia has fired at least 90 missiles
cruise and ballistic missiles into
Ukraine that's about half a billion
dollars worth of of missiles it's done a
lot of damage not to the military of
Ukraine but to the domestic electricity
infrastructure and and that in itself is
a is must be clearly a more shocking
event than one explosion in a field in
Poland well absolutely let's talk about
that and the energy crisis now in
Ukraine and indeed in its neighbors
Moldova reporting power outages the
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
convening a meeting of his defense
Council after crude shipments on a a
pipeline were suspended and the whole of
the hakive region we're told is without
power 80 of leviv and so on you know
what is the strategy from Russia in
order to damage those that crucial
infrastructure as we head into winter in
Ukraine so there appear to be three
parts to the Russian strategy right now
one is to do better on the on on the
battlefield and the withdrawal from
Hearthstone earlier military sense but
was a huge strategic and indeed military
um setback so there's a war on the
battlefield for territory and it's it's
it's frankly not moving very much right
now either way there's a second aspect
to the war in Ukraine which is the war
against the will of the Ukrainian people
to continue in this fight and and Russia
is trying to do that by depriving them
of heat and and light and energy to go
to work and go to school and then
there's a third dimension which to try
to deplete the will of Western Nations
including the UK to support Ukraine by
targeting our cost of living and our
energy supplies and and all of this can
be connected in in a campaign by Russia
to continue to fight this war frankly
with all the means at its at its
disposal military and non-military short
of weapons of mass destruction at least
so far